Speaker 1: I love this story because it combines
radical right wing arrogance with real estate
and tax law, which are all things that I enjoy.
We have now learned that ridiculous radical
right robot Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Green filed homestead exemptions or homestead
declarations as they are sometimes called
on to homes, which is against the law.
This is, as we like to say, a fraud.
She made a fraud.
Let's first talk about homestead exemptions.
A homestead exemption is a legal declaration
that lets you say this home I own.
This is my primary residence.
It is where I am sheltered.
And in exchange for such a declaration, the
value of your home is protected from property
tax claims, from creditors, from forced sales
and a number of other circumstances.
In normal cases, the way debt works in the
US is that you can have situations where you
could be forced to sell an asset to pay off
a creditor or a debt that you owe.
A homestead exemption or declaration lets
you say, this property is my home, this is
my residence, this is where I live.
It's not a second home.
It's not an investment property.
And so by declaring it a homestead, you can't
be forced to sell that home to pay your debts.
They can't leave you homeless to pay your
debts.
This is separate from foreclosure, but it's
a very particular type of declaration.
In some states, only some portion of the home's
value is protected and that amount can vary.
Texas has no dollar value limit.
Some states do.
And additionally, many states give you a tax
break because you do not have to pay property
taxes on some portion of your home's value.
So if a certain state exempts one hundred
thousand dollars of value with a homestead
declaration, if the house is worth five hundred
K, but one hundred K is exempt, you pay property
taxes as if the house were worth only four
hundred thousand.
OK, but here's the rule.
You can only do it on one property.
Channel two Action News in Atlanta did an
investigation and found that Marjorie Taylor
Green and her husband have two active homestead
exemptions, which is against the law in Georgia.
The Greens are getting a tax break on two
homes in two different counties.
Channel two News pulled the Greens homestead
exemption application in Fulton County and
in Floyd County.
Oh, in the Floyd County application.
Marjorie Taylor Green's husband left blank
the line, which says, Do you have an exemption
on another property?
That is a lie by omission.
I recall talking to my real estate attorney
about this a couple of years back and I asked
when we were talking about different transactions
I've been involved in and the Homestead Declaration,
I asked, how often do people get caught for
this?
He said, you know, I know of many people that
do this and they do get away with it.
Marjorie Taylor Green appears to have gotten
caught.
Fulton County tax officials confirm that Green
never stopped getting the tax break on the
Fulton property, but declared it on the Floyd
County property.
Now, there are, at least in theory, consequences
for doing this.
This is defrauding the state.
To be clear, the penalty for filing a false
homestead exemption, according to Georgia
code, is twice your tax bill.
For the Greens, that would be about twelve
thousand dollars.
There were two statements put out by Green's
office.
In the first statement was, this is merely
a pathetic smear.
That was statement number one.
This escalated.
And then the second statement was calling
this fake news and saying this was just an
error by Fulton County.
The the Greens are claiming they requested
the homestead exemption be canceled for the
Fulton County, but maybe because of covid,
I don't know.
They never did it, but now they've got it
all fixed up.
So she's going with that.
She's going with we did everything right,
but something something covid and it prevented
it from happening.
That doesn't explain why they didn't answer
the question.
Do you have an active homestead exemption
on another property right now?
The answer was yes.
They left that blank.
Seems like a clear line by omission.
Maybe it was lost in the mail, which was destroyed
by Donald Trump's crony, Louis Dejoy.
But the simplest explanation is that this
is fraud.
Marjorie Taylor Greene is making up that she
tried canceling it and that they intentionally
lied and they got caught, plain and simple.
Now, the question of whether there will be
considered.
Onesies.
You all know how that works when it comes
to people in positions of power in the United
States.
So I don't know, but I'm certainly not confident
that there will be any consequences.
But an apparent fraud committed by Marjorie
Taylor Green and her husband, the Party of
Rules and Law and Order and all of this stuff.
Don't forget that